[Music]
on this Thursday night the timeline of a
murderous Mission RCMP detailed a rapid
chaotic events of the Rampage on the
James Smith Cree Nation an incredibly
complex
and large-scale investigation how it
unfolded what's still a mystery and the
reaction the troubling history of the
man accused in the Pentagon league and
new questions about how he ever got
hired
feeling like you work eight days a week
I don't take days off why those running
small businesses feel they can't catch a
break and a one-time king of daytime TV
dies they're going to wrestle in
applesauce
Jerry Springer's undeniable influence on
popular culture
foreign
National with Donna freezing good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin in Saskatchewan and the most
detailed timeline yet of one of the
worst mass killings in Canadian history
the rcmpo spent seven months
investigating the multiple murders in a
stabbing Rampage gave a four-hour
presentation today revealing new details
about the chaotic brutal events 11
people were killed during the attack on
the James Smith Cree Nation and in
nearby weld in Saskatchewan 17 others
were injured it happened last September
and ended after a four-day Manhunt the
RCMP release today is distressing and
detailed revealing how 32-year-old miles
Sanderson carried out his murderous
Mission RCMP investigators and
specialists documented examined and
processed 42 different crime scenes
buildings Vehicles over 1 250
investigative tasks have been assigned
and new tasks continue to be identified
the scope of today's presentation
delivered some answers to family and
friends who lost loved ones last fall
but to many questions remain about the
police response and sanderson's motive
Melissa ridgeen has our top story
tonight
it has been and continues to be an
incredibly complex
and large-scale investigation
of what the details are unimaginable the
rcmp's timeline begins on September 1st
three days before The Killing Spree what
we know now miles and Damian Sanderson
were on a days long booze and cocaine
fueled bender and escalating as they
committed break-ins assault and car
thefts at James Smith cremation and the
paradis closed to some that they had
quote a mission that people would
remember something police did not know
until it was too late according to
police Damien was actually the first
homicide victim in the early morning
hours of September 4th when an argument
inside a stolen van turned deadly Damien
escaped the van and died of his injuries
his body was found in a bushed area on
September 5th miles alone went on a
reign of terror through James Smith Cree
Nation driving from house to house
breaking in armed with a knife to attack
those he found inside his attacks were
unpredictable as fast as information
would come it was coming in about a
vehicle he was in he was abandoning that
vehicle moving on foot it and then
stealing other vehicles after his
brother miles first victim was Robert
Sanderson attacked just after 6 a.m he
then appeared at the house of Christian
and Lana head killing the pair before
taking off in their truck a series of
assaults unfolded before miles entered a
home where Gregory Burns was attacked
the 28 year old was said to have run
outside where he later died miles
sanderson's next victim was Earl Burns
an indigenous veteran who'd attempted to
chase miles down in a school bus that he
drove in the community The Killing Spree
continued at another home where he
attacked Thomas and Carol Burns followed
by another series of assaults before his
last victims on James Smith Cree Nation
Lydia and Bonnie Burns miles Sanderson
then made his way to nearby Weldon where
he killed 78-year-old Wesley Peterson
from the first stabbing to the last two
hours elapsed while police scrambled in
his wake calling in additional resources
from across the region and Province this
investigation equates to 11 separate
homicide investigations
and 17 separate attempted murder
investigations
Melissa this is so much information for
family and friends of the victims to
take in the RCMP did brief them ahead of
this press conference today what do they
make of it all Donna there's still a lot
of unanswered questions and the big
question is why which we may never know
as the two men with that answer are both
Dead Daryl Burns is the brother of one
of the victims Lydia Burns a community
crisis worker who was killed when she
went to help an earlier victim he had
this to say about the police response
hearing this and watching it on a funny
screen and realizing not how much chaos
and confusion and Terror that was
happening that morning like like how
could anyone know how could anyone know
where he was and where he was going to
go and what he was going to do that
grieving brother says that everyone
involved his sister and the Killer is a
victim of drugs and another death in
this the community's crisis response
team he says that it's unclear what the
future holds for that it was set up to
help with suicides not mass murders next
will be two inquiries to fill in more
blanks and possible improvements that
could be made going forward Donna all
right Melissa Ridge in Melford
Saskatchewan tonight thanks nearly two
weeks after intense fighting broke out
in Sudan Canada has finally started
airlifting people out two Canadian
military flights left Sudan today the
government says the first carried 45
people the second 73 people though it's
not clear how many of those on board
were Canadians
all options are on the table planning is
occurring as we speak to ensure the
maximum number of Canadians can be
evacuated as soon as possible there is
no word on when the next flights might
leave the situation on the ground is
getting worse power outages are leading
to shortages of water and food a fragile
ceasefire has been extended another 72
hours the country's rival military
forces apparently agreeing to the Troops
prime minister Justin Trudeau is in New
York City today at the global citizen
conference along with politicians
philanthropists and celebrities it's
focused on global issues such as climate
change food insecurity and international
human rights critics are quick to point
out the contradiction between attending
an event like this when at the same time
the liberal government is cutting
foreign aid funding by a billion dollars
this year itugarcha reports from New
York
prime minister Justin Trudeau is in New
York City at an event Global citizen
organizers say aims to end extreme
poverty
he started with a meeting at the United
Nations with Barbados prime minister Mia
Motley we're at
to the deadline for the sustainable
development goals and we have a lot of
work to do still but back home some in
the Canadian International Aid sector
say they're surprised to see Trudeau at
a high profile conference on
international human rights when the
Liberals are set to scale back Aid
funding to some of the world's poorest
countries by 1.3 billion dollars cut
foreign aid by 15 uh for one year
um you know there's consequences with
your partners uh in the global South
there's consequences right here at home
with Canadian Aid sector who are pretty
unhappy conservative leader Pierre
pauliev also criticizing the trip in
question period Wednesday singing Frank
Sinatra's New York New York while
slamming Trudeau for not staying home
during the federal Public Service strike
he wants to be a part of it New York New
York but Canada's ambassador to the U.S
says the trip is important for doubling
down on U.S investments in Canada
penetrating into the U.S
media World penetrating into the U.S
business Community is much better done
in person as International Development
Minister harjit sajan defends the
Liberals Aid funding cut he announced
195 million dollars to expand the
program supporting women's rights
organizations around the world the
Mainline budget allows us to keep
programs going so for example no no
programs have been cut we
spent extra significant amounts because
of the pandemic because of the war in
Ukraine because of what's happening in
Afghanistan what's happening elsewhere
so we spiked up tremendously but the
Baseline continues to go Trudeau has
been promoted by global citizen as one
of the prominent figures at this event
he said to make a keynote address on
Friday and he's expected to meet with
the Council on Foreign Relations to
speak about the importance of the
critical mineral supply chain the
country's economic Outlook and Canada
U.S relations on the heels of President
Biden's visit to Ottawa last month Donna
all right neither garcha New York City
tonight thanks
in Taiwan polls suggests the desire for
unification with China has never been
more unpopular but for people in at
least one area of the self-governed
Democracy opinions are more divided Jing
man Island sits just a few kilometers
from mainland China and is governed by
Taiwan about 70 thousand people live
there if the Chinese military were to
invade Taiwan those people could be on
the front lines our Jeff Semple went to
find out what it's like living at the
center of that decades-long tension
blacksmith Wu sang dong runs this
workshop on taiwan's jingman island he
Prides himself on making something good
out of something terrible
woo forges household knives made with
steel from old Chinese bombs artillery
shells that landed here decades ago and
on this island he's not running short of
material
I was only a few months old when the
artillery battle started but the
fighting continued for many years he
says jingman island is caught in the
middle of a frozen conflict this
Taiwanese territory is far from Taipei
but just a couple of kilometers from
mainland China and 74 years ago Jing men
became a front line This Island is
littered with remnants of War a civil
war that in 1949 saw jingman Island torn
apart from the mainland the Communists
took control of mainland China and the
nationalists fled taking control of
Taiwan and jingmon Island among others
over 20 years the Chinese fired on the
island hundreds of thousands of times
supplying shells for Woo's Workshop
he says the shelling happened every
other night his family and others
huddled in shelters and bunkers waiting
for the bombing to stop now he fears
history is poised to repeat
the Chinese government has vowed to take
Taiwan by force if necessary its
military running drills rehearsing an
invasion the vast majority of Taiwanese
oppose joining China but in jingman
Island feelings are mixed
if the Communists are coming let them
come says this 66 year old his father
fought the Chinese military and he grew
up under the bombing but still
Chinese and Taiwanese people are the
same he says same ancestors and language
Chinese people will no longer fight
their own people that Affinity is also
explained by necessity
Beijing recently started supplying
drinking water to stabilize the Island's
Supply and a ferry service now shuttles
passengers back and forth to China
a significant portion of jingman's
economy relies on tourism and
small-scale trade with China says this
local representative of taiwan's ruling
party but closer ties with communist
China doesn't mean they're willing to
give up their Democratic freedoms
every day the speaker tower broadcasts
music and a message to China by the late
Taiwanese singer and pro-democracy
activist Teresa Tang
it is my fervent hope that our fellow
citizens on Mainland China can enjoy the
same democracy and freedom that we have
here it says we enjoy our system our
practical system here this gingman
congresswoman explains the main
difference between Taiwanese mainlanders
and Islanders the island I think more
than Taiwan did experience
and people here remember what it cost
it is crucial that we strive to prevent
any War Wu says it would bring great
suffering to both sides Jeff Semple
Global News jingman Island
the 21 year old U.S national guard
Airmen accused of posting classified
documents online has a history of making
threats and researched mass shootings
that's according to U.S justice
department lawyers Jack Teixeira was in
court today Federal prosecutors want him
kept in custody saying the military I.T
specialist is both a national security
threat and a serious Flight Risk court
documents filed Wednesday by federal
prosecutors say to Shara accessed
hundreds of classified documents for
over a year far exceeding what has been
publicly disclosed they allege he has a
troubling history of behavior including
making racist and violent threats in
high school researching mass shootings
on government computers and amassing an
arsenal of weapons including a bazooka
in his bedroom it's alleged he wrote on
social media that he wanted to kill a
ton of people as a way of culling the
weak-minded and that he appears to have
taken a series of obstructive steps
intended to thwart the government's
ability to ascertain the full scope of
what he has obtained
well some people are working for the
weekend but for small business owners
that break never comes we'll tell you
why coming up
foreign
if you're a small business owner you
know how hard it is to take time off
Canada's labor shortage is having an
impact across all businesses but it's
felt most acutely by small businesses
new data from the Canadian Federation of
Independent Business shows owners are
taking on more hours and more
responsibilities and as Ann gabiola
explains that it's taking a toll
I don't take days off I just take little
pieces of time during each day to try
and fit in
my personal life basically most every
waking moment of Jen newark's life is
spent working or thinking about her
boutique grocery store for pets her
story is typical of entrepreneurs
running small businesses with those in
hospitality and agriculture most likely
to work overtime the average small
business owner dealing with a worker
shortage puts in nearly 60 hours a week
according to polling by the cfib that's
the equivalent of seven and a half eight
hour shifts in a single week hiring at
pet grocer has become particularly
challenging given the tight labor market
the last time we did a job ad we had
very few applicants and of those
applicants none of them met the criteria
of what we had just listed in the ads
the cfib says the shortage holds back a
company's ability to grow and innovate
impacts of flavor surgeries is they have
to turn down sales or contracts and also
they decrease their service offerings it
can also lead to burnout blurring the
lines between work and personal life
it can be overwhelming and I know that
sometimes my family and friends is
understanding as they are get a little
bit frustrated small businesses expect
to increase wages by an average of 3.3
percent in the next year according to
the cfib now that is welcome news for
prospective workers though still well
below the rate of inflation Donna
all right and give Yola in Toronto
thanks ahead encouraging signs about
access to palliative care in Canada
[Music]
for vulnerable patients especially those
needing end-of-life care being pain-free
and comfortable and keeping their
dignity is so important a new study
suggests the number of Canadians who
need palliative care and get it has gone
up over the past two years Catherine
Ward explains why it makes such a
difference for families and what still
needs to change
this spoon
and my line there is no negativity when
Shannon Murray thinks about her mom
Bonnie she doesn't focus on the stage 4
cancer that took her life at the age of
73. instead Yuri thinks of her positive
spirit
he was just delight and love and and
full of inspiration and tenacity Wonder
Woman Bonnie was told she only had six
months to live she fought for another
three years at the end Miri says
palliative care was a blessing for the
whole family they know what to recognize
and they know how to offer the support
and in your time of need or in your
loved one time of need that is
invaluable the study shows 58 percent of
Canadians who died between 2021 and 2022
received palliative care an increase
from 52 percent five years ago
analysts say this is in part because of
a push to help Canadians age in place
and get better access to end-of-life
support whether at home hospice or in
the hospital still experts say there is
room for improvement often what we can
see is from time of admission uh the
majority of folks die within about 30
days of that admission so that right
away suggests to us that those folks
were not identified early enough the
numbers show cancer patients are more
likely to receive care typically
depending on the cancer people follow a
more linear trajectory in their
diagnosis it's a little bit easier to
know when to initiate a palliative care
approach and offer a palliative care
approach this is very different from
other diagnoses like congestive heart
failure COPD Strokes or dementia which
have some sometimes very unpredictable
ups and downs to the trajectory as
Murray experienced having full support
can provide unexpected peace even while
preparing for the end no matter how many
struggles we had in life
that as long as we had each other we
were always going to be okay
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing was too much next The Life and
Legacy of talk show host Jerry Springer
[Music]
there was no subtlety to Jerry
Springer's talk show from stripper Wars
to honey I'm a call girl and even I
married a horse no topic was too much
Jerry Springer has died at the age of
79. he started off mild-mannered but
then he veered into showcasing
dysfunctional and outrageous
relationships even he admitted the show
that ran for nearly three decades was
stupid but he called critics of it
elitist said it was always about real
people and millions of people tuned in
to watch Mike Armstrong on who Springer
was and what he left behind
[Applause]
there was a time when this wasn't normal
whether it was Brotherhood betrayal or a
battling bride daytime TV shows haven't
always needed bouncers
well that was before the Jerry Springer
Show
foreign
ly apologize I've ruined the culture
all right now I can see what they're
fighting over okay what's going on here
the show ran for 27 seasons and made
Springer a household name it was
syndicated in other countries and other
languages and it was a platform to other
opportunities Springer played Captain
Hook on the stage in London well I've
never played a bad guy before because
you know even on my show I'm the good
guy and everyone else is crazy here is
your ex-boyfriend Dennis
you're never seemed
to tow too seriously TV Guide named it
the worst show of all time but Springer
said it wasn't for the critics or even
for himself I was hired to be a
ringleader of a circus I am hosting a
show about outrageousness Springer was
born in London to Jewish parents who
escaped Germany during the Holocaust he
was raised in New York went into law
then politics in 1977 he was elected
Mayor of Cincinnati thank you for
letting the son of refugees of Nazi
Germany Make It in America thank you
Iraqi air defense base Springer's next
career was as a journalist then came the
jump to daytime TV in 1991 with a show
that Springer would joke likely lasted
too long we're starting to get the kids
of our original guest son and this is
wrong because these people were told not
to procreate well Springer's show also
spawned imitators other programs that he
would say went too far good that was a
criticism also leveled at Springer that
he exploited his guests but Springer
insisted he was showing a part of
American life and Americans that
otherwise weren't seen on television
Mike Armstrong Global News
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is the Canadian Rockies near
Camrose Alberta thanks for watching
Faron Nasser will be here at the anchor
desk tomorrow and I'll see you on
Saturday for the new reality bye-bye
[Music]
thank you